that Russia has admitted it is under
pressure from Ukrainian forces as it
battles to retake areas in the Southeast
Russia's faced a series of setbacks in
recent weeks and in a rare admission its
new commander in Ukraine says the
situation in Herson is tense Russia's
preparing to evacuate some civilians
from the region
the situation in the Curson area is not
simple
the enemy is intentionally hitting
economic social industrial
infrastructure and residential buildings
in Curson our priority will be to save
the lives of civilians in our military
we will act consciously in a timely
manner and we will not exclude making
difficult decisions
is live for us now in Kiev so Muhammad
first of all what more do we know at the
moment about the situation in Herson
well it has them it's very interesting
uh this statement from the new commander
of Russian forces in Ukraine the fact
that he is admitting that the situation
is difficult that is suggesting to a lot
of analysts and a lot of people here in
Ukraine that this is an apparent
concession uh that there is a danger of
Ukrainian advances or more advances
towards Harrison you have other Russian
installed officials in the southern
region that are also announcing that
there has been this gradual organized
what they're calling evacuation of of
civilians from from parts of the
southern region and parts of her son you
also have not had any confirmation from
the Ukrainian military command as to
what's happening in Hassan now this is
effectively a blackout on their military
operations in the South and typically
that happens here in Ukraine when there
is fierce fighting going on when there
is that Fierce counter-offensive which
we know has been going on for quite some
time there have been in some indication
some subtle indications from officials
here in the past few days that Ukraine
does believe that it is making
significant advances in Herson and that
there is a belief among some people in
the government here that perhaps Garcon
could be retaken by ukrainians but all
we've heard officially from the military
command in the south is that there is an
active defense by Ukrainian soldiers
there on the front to hold their
occupied lines they're talking about
mikalayev Carson zapparija as well they
have stated the Ukrainian Southern
military command and stated that the
Russians are continuing to inflict
damage on our troops using aviation
artillery and Rockets and they've also
said that Russian ammunition Depots
tanks and armored vehicles have been
destroyed by the Ukrainian military
what are we hearing about the uh efforts
by ukrainians to to repair those damaged
power plants how's that going
well housing what we've heard from
officials is that those repairs are
ongoing but this is coming at a time
when it is getting colder here because
winter is approaching so the fact that
you've had a third of the of the power
structure in this country either damaged
or destroyed since October 10th that is
causing officials to warn people here
that even though the grid is being
repaired every day when more damage is
being inflicted they are concerned that
things could get worse I'll give you an
example yesterday you had three missile
strikes hit power facilities in the
destiansky district of Kiev that's to
the east of the capital we went out to
the destiniansky district just hours
after those strikes had happened we
talked to Residents who didn't have
power at that time now as of today power
has been restored but yesterday when we
were out there residents were telling us
just how concerned they were about what
could be happening next here's our
report
a barrage of missile strikes across
Ukraine hitting critical infrastructure
the second day the country's power grid
has come under attack
like at this plant in denipro
and this one inches
Ukrainian officials expect more attacks
in the days ahead the
terrorist States Russia is making every
effort to destroy the Ukrainian Energy
System the main target is not only the
peacefully Ukrainian civilians but also
critical infrastructure
in kiev's destinyansky District power
facilities were hit by three missiles
leaving many areas in the dark
for residents of this apartment complex
concerns are growing
they have done the same again last
Monday and today they attacked us again
and it wasn't just the electricity they
worried about
water wasn't flowing either
63 year old Valentina has lived in this
neighborhood for 30 years and she's
upset
this time they hit the factory as a
conclusion we have no electricity and no
hot water and children cannot study at
home or at school
this is very painful
very painful for our children and
grandchildren
for now the residents wait hoping
utilities will come back online soon
Ukrainian officials say 30 percent of
the country's power plants have been
damaged by Russian shelling since
October 10th and add that more blackouts
are possible they're urging citizens to
limit their consumption of electricity a
critical warning as winter approaches
and temperatures continue to drop